the World Health Organization has warned
that cases of monkey pox are spreading
rapidly more than 100 cases have now
been reported here in Europe as well as
in North America but officials say that
this outbreak can be contained and that
there's no evidence of the virus
mutating Health authorities in Austria
and Denmark today announced their first
cases now this comes as more cases have
been identified in the UK here in
Germany and in other countries where the
disease is usually not found
but we asked epidemiologist Eric feigel
Dean how alarmed he is by the rising
number of cases worldwide
well the rising cases has really
concerning uh last Friday we only had
100 cases now we're over 200. UK cases
have gone from 20 to now 56 cases
from Friday to Monday and uh you know
Portugal is well over 100 cases and
Portugal is a relatively small country
so I I think this surge is it's only
going to increase further because the
incubation time for this virus is much
longer than it was for covid and the
mortality we you know we the West
African strain traditionally has a one
percent mortality but right now the
issue is the the sequence the virus it
has over 50 mutations
um different than previous versions and
so now we don't really know like what
does that mean in terms of
contagiousness severity we don't know
but clearly we've never had so many
multi-country simultaneous rise in
monkeypox before like this especially in
the triple digits or an exponential rise
like this and Aaron do we have Clarity
tonight on exactly how monkeypox is
being spread and apparently so quickly
yeah you know there is discussion that
it's sexually transmitted but obviously
traditionally with monkey pox you also
can have direct contact with scabs with
bodily fluids
um it's well known and CDC has
acknowledged that it's theoretically
possible that it is aerosol Airborne
um and therefore they recommend you take
precautions against aerosol transmission
until we learn more because we've we
have to have the humidity humility to
know that you know many uh you know two
years ago we said oh it's just the flu
for covid oh it wasn't Airborne but did
turn out to be airborne it did turn out
to have lots of reinfection potential
and it wasn't just the flu so with a
specially new virus potentially a new
version of this virus potentially with
50 mutations we have to be extra
precautious until we learn more and in
some countries and I'm talking about
right here in Germany as well there are
no recommendations where right now in
terms of what people should do regarding
monkey pox what would your
recommendation be tonight
well I think first of all be very
careful about any close contact so we'll
definitely wash your hands Anna you know
what masking may have a double benefit
against both covid and potentially
monkeypox if this theoretically Airborne
is true we should really it's supported
by uh experimental evidence as well so
we should really take the same
precautions as covid but also look for
any rashes and welts that are unusual
because normally we have rashes and all
the time but now during the age of
monkeypox we should be extra careful in
terms of surveilling for this because
this has a long human time and by the
time you know for sure that these boils
start servicing over your face and body
it might be too late it may have already
passed to others so earlier detection
right now being vigilant is really key
yeah and as you say those masks they you
know are worth their weight in gold
that's for sure epidemiologist Eric
feigledine as always Eric we appreciate
your time and your insights thank you
basic